here we have a tricky question where X
and Y are fractions and we need to
compute the product of X and Y to solve
this problem we utilize the fact that 1
is equal to 1 squared which is equal to
1 cubed then we apply the difference of
squares and difference in sum of Cube's
formulas here we have difference of
squares here we have a sum of cubes here
we have a difference of Cubes we
substitute these in and then we can
simplify the fractions we can further
simplify the product of X and Y and
everything will magically cancel out so
the product is equal to 1 which is
answer Choice e there's another way you
could solve this problem by using
estimation when you have the square or
cube of a large number and you add or
subtract a small number the estimated
value will approximately be equal to the
square or cube of the large number we
can apply this to get estimated values
of X and Y we can simplify these
estimated values further
then we can take the estimated product
of X and Y and this will work out to be
approximately one so once again the
answer is e